ok so then puppet what's the first time
when it is 30 meters to the right the
origin 30 meters to the left of the
origin and secrete to four significant
figures ok let's have a look so they
want to know when flat and when it's
right interestingly and they said four
words the first time so that's a little
bit strange I've met a wonder maybe if
they've just make things up let's go
with the convention is that wishes you
usually say four words is positive out
of left to right which will be usually
stay positive out of left and right
pepper we would usually say to the right
okay which means by the way which means
I'd like when you look at this right
remember this x-axis here this is X and
this is time ok which way do you look at
it which way is right well I'm saying
this positive directions to the right so
you're actually have to turn your head
if you're looking at it this way you
turn your head like that is that make
sense because then you can see are now
this is going to the right this is going
to the left so time is going down this
way ok I'm just cleaning that out
because a little bit weird to think are
left right but I've drawn a lot of
vertical axis ok so that's a bit weird
just learn that you have to watch out
for them I'm going to say to the right
is positive so for the first one part 1
I want to know I want to solve for x
equals positive one of you this is to
the right so I'm going to say 430 so
it's actually do this i got my
displacement function right over there
so I'm going to say 120 side that equals
30
and now you can see why they asked for
four significant figures because you've
got nothing big coming out of this right
now it does say great what's the first
time doing it has to be the first time
right because clearly is an infinite
number of time so what I do with this
I'm going to use my industry so i'm
going to say apply on 12 t equals sine
inverse of the quarter yep okay and then
you're gonna have to give you a number
here can someone give me a number when
you get this 0.96 five mins yeah it has
it can I actually get a few more decimal
places just for the sake of it because I
always write down more and then I come
watch me someone got one for that I
wiped off my answer yeah there's gin
what did you do ever got some buddies in
the robot always writing this really
feel absolutely that this is very true
okay someone give it up Nikki will do a
pasta from scratch all over
616 8174 3000 okay fantastic thank you I
just wanted to draw that because because
we don't look at some things very much
as geniuses there will always be a
rounded question decimal places to do
figures significantly much more
challenging because when you gotta think
more carefully about it the zeros not
significant okay in fact any number of
zeros up until the first non-zero digit
I'm on significant you only start
getting zero in here which is
significant so therefore like Nikita
said I'm going to go one two three four
significant figures and i'm going to
write that i should also provide them
unit okay now competence check that's a
small number it's quite small then what
does it make sense hmm how would we how
could you argue that this number makes
sense to someone who's just looking at
this hasn't done all the calculus in
wetherby yeah for your poster saying it
takes 12 seconds yeah it takes six
seconds ok so what rough is talking
about because in case you're not quite
connecting the dots is that this is my
very rough drawing of the displacement
function right I know the period is 24
seconds so where does that belong on my
set message is right there at the end
isn't it snares 20 feel right which
means that for example starting your
again how longs it take me to travel and
then come back to the origin that's a
common question it's just half a period
right which means to get to my extremity
of motion 120 meters away how long does
that take me it's a quarter of the
period right a half a top okay so it
takes you six seconds to travel that far
six seconds okay so i can work out of
average speeds but notice when do I
travel quickly next I travel quickly
when i'm close to the origin right which
is where at the beginning right so these
first 30 meters they flash by like that
the last thing is they take much longer
right
don't you work out how low it takes to
do the last 30 mins green okay for a
time let me think about this we use this
method to find out how long went to how
long it took to go the first 30 years
how would it take pillow what would I do
to work out how long it takes me to the
lines I anything- yeah so what I would
probably do is just like I've solved
here for x equals that's hundred twenty
rain I've solved for x equals 30
probably a lot ways it is but from my
brain the first place I go is solve for
x equals 19 right because that's where
the last 30 meters big ears I already
know where the last 30 meters ends and
then you can come up with a time okay um
let's just try that out I mean let's
just see what's different have a look if
I solve x equals 19 this is just going
to be 90 days only three quarters three
quarters three quarters can someone give
me a number so give it up us right oh
gee it's like negative no it's not it
shouldn't be is this Oh ahh okay all
right oh this is more interesting than
that thought which is good can I get a
number okay let's get the number of t
equals what out of this no no just just
tell mocha numbers as in like the key
value point three point because it's not
past have you got a native four threes
not possible hey remember that moment
was the farm animal what was my point
why why was it interesting than the
timing tonight okay so tight x to get to
90 is 3.2 seconds so therefore how long
does it take me to get from 90 to 120 6
minus that right six MOS that two point
eight ish seconds almost well is it
three times longer than that yeah does
that make sense it does right cuz look
at the beginning of your journey you
gone super quick right that's why it's
so steep and at the end you're going
super slow right three times though or
an average okay so that's why that part
didn't take so long